notable quotables straight to a Fox News
Alert Roger stone is indicted by a grand
jury
[Applause]
federal workers who are going to
homeless shelters well I know they are
and I don't really quite understand why
and this is the less I make a kind of
attitude I'm getting hundreds and
hundreds of reports I can't come to work
anymore I am running for president in
the United States
BuzzFeed just got it wrong we expect the
United Kingdom to tell us what they want
what they really really want you can try
to teach a goat how to climb a tree
which is better off hiring a scorer from
the first place
it's terrible people have he didn't have
a maggot hat and that was not a pro-life
protest this would not be a story it was
a low point I think in history for the
Speaker of the House we need a physical
barrier that you can't crawl under climb
over drive-through or walk around
nicolas maduro is a dictator with no
legitimate claim to power
that's what socialism gets you how many
do you give there we have reached a deal
to end the shutdown and reopen the
federal government I had been very clear
on the wall hopefully now the president
has learned his lesson there's a week